alors à québec on retrouve jean
st-gelais jean françois chalifoux
messieurs bonsoir
dites nous pourquoi après 80 ans à peu
près d'existence pour vos deux deux
entreprises vos deux mutuelles
pourquoi aujourd'hui en 2020 il est
pertinent pour vous de fusionner ce
projet là découle de noeux d'une vision
commune de demeurer concurrentiels et
maintenir un siège social fort à québec
nous croyons qu'il s'agit d'un excellent
scénario pour rehausser à continuer
d'offrir à nos clients une expérience
uniques et distinctives ainsi que
d'offrir des contextes de travail et des
défis stimulants pour tous nos employés
au canada
et pourquoi monsieur st gelais c'est
monsieur chalifoux qui sera pdg et vous
vous en allez président du conseil
d'administration de la nouvelle entité
actu on est très très heureux
on en attendre qu'on entre nous moi
j'étais content que jean-françois il a
accepté le rôle de pdg
on a quelqu'un qui connaît l'industrie
de fond en comble une intelligence vive
prise de décision rapide
en ce sens je pense qu'on va faire une
bonne équipe
voilà puis on en est venu à cette
entente là parce qu'à part un pdg ce
après un président de conseil et
évidemment puis devant des défis comme
jean-françois nous parler édifiant
technologies d'information des
investissements à faire que présentement
on fait de la recherche de la meilleure
pour le futur a l'impression que qui
assure la réduction des coûts le capital
réglementaire exigé par la haye mais
fait tout le monde ça fait plein de sens
de se regrouper regrouper nos forces
puis donc vous trouverez des synergies
vous trouver des synergies vous dites
qu'au jour 1 il y aura 4700 employés
mais ce qui aura des compressions et ce
qui aurait des suppressions d'emplois
l'objectif l'autre derrière ce
regroupement leur set générer de la
croissance et assurer la pérennité de
nos organisations donc nous souhaitons
claque que la nouvelle organisation soit
pérenne bien évidemment donc par
conséquent on se met en mode davantage
de créer un des emplois durables et bien
rémunérés et évidemment vers toi
d'envergure est-ce que sur les 4700 il y
en aura - compte tenu qu aura des
synergies aller chercher c'est ce que
j'allais dire c'est une opération
d'envergure
il y avait assurément dans ce contexte
des réaménagements d'effectifs
il y aura des départs pour toutes sortes
de raisons comme il y en aurait eu si
nous étions demeurer indépendant mais
sachez qu'au cours des prochaines années
nous anticipons 500 départs à la
retraite
nous avons plus 200 postes qui sont
actuellement vacants ici à québec dans
tous nos bureaux ailleurs au canada
c'est plus de 200 postes vacants donc au
global
nous serons en mode croissance donc 500
postes des départs à la retraite et 200
postes vacants qui ne seront pas
remplacés
c'est ça non non non non pas du tout ça
c'est sans compter les noix contrat sans
compter les dotations qu'ont effectué à
chaque année notons qu'en dowie je
redirai à majorque typhon se retrouver
avec un dd nouvelle équipe perdre et des
départs il ya des gens qui quittent non
maman de l'attrition naturelle de 5 à
10% par année au sein nos deux
organisations donc air ou global oui il
y aura des synergies bien entendu mais
y'avait pas de mises à pied massives
ok mais généralement lorsqu'on annonce
ce genre de choses là on nous donne un
chiffre à savoir est ce que il peut y
avoir cinq cent mille postes de moins
non écoutez on nous on est beaucoup plus
en france seules expliquer en mode on
veut que l'entreprise croit vivre la
voie de la croissance dans
l'organisation d'au qu on aura embauché
pour la croissance qu'on aura vite fait
en même temps on a un défi parce que les
gens qui quittent - les gens recrutés ce
défi de pénurie de main-d'oeuvre qu'on a
autre connais pas on n'est pas en reste
canalisations mais évidemment reprendre
juste le personnel nécessaire pour faire
les opérations qu'on a à faire mais on
veut croire en vous êtes plus de monde
pour ça on veut mieux faire ce qu'on
fait actuellement en cours à cette
transaction est avantageuse pour vos
clients et vos membres
on se donne aujourd'hui les moyens
[Musique]
d'investir
face aux défis qui nous guette
d'investir dans nos hautes technologies
livrer une expérience client distinctive
nos clients ont des attentes en matière
d'habitudes de consommation par rapport
révèle de plus en plus interagir
directement via des technologies
numériques
donc c'est tout ce que nous sommes nous
donnons comme option dès maintenant est
ce que les changements climatiques vous
oblige à l'union d'aujourd'hui vous
amène à cela en fait compte tenu de
l'impact quand même important sur le
monde des assurances
écoutez c'est un des facteurs qui et qui
fait en sorte que le regroupement prend
tout son sens les changements
climatiques tous les tous les assureurs
à travers le monde doivent dorénavant
prendre en considération parce que c'est
là le nouveau normal qu'on voit ou est
ce que ce n'est quelques années plus
difficiles puis qu'on va rentrer dans en
plus qu'on avait auparavant on se donne
des moyens de mieux apprécier les
risques associés au changement
climatique qu'ils mettent en place les
outils pour y faire face dans voiture
pour nos clients le mieux possible
ça affecte vos résultats écoutez ça fait
que les résultats de tous les assureurs
je dois vous dire que cette année le
début de l'année prise assureurs de
dommages a été particulièrement
difficile mais que la deuxième partie de
l'année s'est mieux déroulé alors à
chacun évidemment
au québec on connaît le climat les
intempéries qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent
faire puis oui on est là pour nos
clients puis quand on paie plus
d'indemnités de nos clients parce qu'ils
ont payé pour sa saison et c'est notre
rôle de le faire également
j'étais moins bonne année changement
changement de nos avenirs absolument
absolument nouveau siège social
une nouvelle identité de marque le siège
social demeure à québec
oui et donc cesser pour que la nouvelle
identité
c'est un projet la faune à maurs dès
maintenant et nous avons mandaté une
firme spécialisée en image de marque
pour nous accompagner dans cette
démarche lors que l'on veut faire avec
nos employés se veut un projet inclusive
participative on souhaite que la
nouvelle identité de marque de marque
soit représentative de la nouvelle
vision de cette nouvelle entreprise que
l'on crée aujourd'hui je vous souhaite
bonne chance merci messieurs pour cet
entretien ce soir nous saisit au plaisir